je m'appelle et semé je suis la plus
grande looseuse de tout le lycée tu pars
travailler
non pourquoi tu dis ça parce que tu es
habillée comme un éboueur sétif à lui
ses grands airs de princesse me donne
envie de vomir
c'était me dire ce qu une date comme toi
va faire dans le monde de la mode dans
les regarde toi un peu à partir
d'aujourd'hui la donne va changer
bienvenue chez wal fadjri la fecq
ouais assieds toi
entités qu'elle ouais moi aussi
et je mataly 10 d'entre eux furent un
post sur twitter témoin pour cela on
vous trouve fabuleux spontané voulait
que j'écrive pour ol fashioned au môle
fashion adorerait que la mort est qu'ici
sexy les uns très belle elle est
incroyable l'isie ne crée pas la mode
elle est la mode
la route je suis l'isi bande de pétales
désolé je t'avais pas reconnue sur la
tête de maquillage
mais pourquoi tu m'as pas rappelé ah
ouais j'ai été super occupé à temps tu
vas quand même publier ça sur ton blog
après écoute il adore l'isi lui et tous
les autres visiteurs l'ebit pas moi que
tout va bien je pensais que ça pouvait
être sympa avec moi pour une fois